>>Cantor: Sense of belonging is one
of the most important activators
of a child's engagement in learning.
>>Darling-Hammond: As human beings,
one of the most essential needs
we have is the need to belong.
When that sense of belonging is
there, children throw themselves
into the learning environment and when
that sense of belonging is not there,
children will alienate, they will
marginalize, they will step back.
>>Cantor: Norms are a way that
we know whether we belong or not.
>>Shaddox: What does social
studies today look like, feel like,
and sound like when we're
supporting the norms?
>>To begin nearly every
class, I start with the norms.
>>We developed this list
of about ten adjectives.
>>Abdurrahmani: Our norms are
communicative, collaborative, zealous,
and the most important
ones: focused and serene.
>>Cantor: This teacher engaged the
class in establishing a set of norms.
So, by having children themselves create
the norms you are creating a pathway
toward belonging for every single child
in that class and they have a role
in this learning community that
they had a share in building.
>>Shaddox: Come up with a statement.
What does social studies look like?
What does it feel like and what does
it sound like? And use those adjectives
that we brainstormed
together for our norms.
>>Student: Social studies is
collaborative. Everybody's kind
of working together.
>>Ali: We get to choose
norms we think will help us
with our work and get it done.
>>Cantor: This teacher created a
common language with which to talk
about our learning community.
>>Shaddox: Let's start
at this table right here.
>>Abdurrahmani: It looks
and should feel focused.
>>If we weren't focused we
wouldn't get any work done.
If we weren't communicative,
you might, like,
have someone struggling in the group.
>>We can suggest to the group we should
be able to stay at a controlled tone.
>>Shaddox: Great, thank you guys
for reflecting on those norms
and we're going to think about
those as we continue our work today.
>>The classes that go really well are
the classes when I start off reflecting
on the norms and using those norms to
articulate how our class will run well.
>>Abdurrahmani: But sometimes it's
good to take some of the norms outside.
>>Shaddox: All right, we want
to do just a quick circle,
set the norms for the game
today, for Capture the Flag.
>>One of our norms is to be
serene. But there might be a class
where there's an activity that requires
a lot of walking around, movement,
even noise, and, you know,
on those days we recognize
that today that's not
going to be our norm.
>>Abdurrahmani: You have to be
inclusive. You have to include everyone.
So, like, it could make
the game better, more fun,
and you could have a
better chance of winning.
>>Shaddox: Sweet, inclusive.
>>It helps us own the
behavior in the classroom.
Instead of a top-down list of rules that
a teacher gives a class, these are words
that we generated together.
These are words that we believe in.
>>Shaddox: Inclusive,
focused, considerate.
>>Abdurrahmani: Zealous.
>>Shaddox: Being zealous. Great.